let's talk about slopes of linear
functions a function is increasing if
it's graph moves upward from left to
right okay so this I'm sure you've seen
before the input the output when you
draw the graph that is the set of all
points that satisfy that rule if that
line is increasing then we call it an
increasing function this is a linear
function insofar as it has a positive it
has a constant slope throughout all
values of X you could formally define an
increasing function f of X such that for
any two x's for any X one that's greater
than x2 F of x1 is also greater than f
of x2 similarly you could define a
decreasing function in the same way you
would simply reverse the inequality
function is decreasing if for any x1
greater than X 2 f of x1 is less than f
of X 2 okay so as you increase X f of X
goes down so this is a very common
problem obviously in in science or in
policy you're often looking at variables
to try to determine whether they have
whether the function that relates those
two variables is increasing or
decreasing while this seems very simple
in reality what you'll be doing and
we'll see this to two sessions from now
is that you will observe phenomena for
example X might be investment in
education by low-cal per capita let's
say and this might be test score
outcomes and you'll observe lots of
paired variables and you might plot them
on a graph and you might want to figure
out whether it has an increasing slope
or a decreasing slope or has no slope at
all and that's precisely what ordinary
least-squares regression is all about
right okay okay so what's a linear
function it's one where the graph is a
straight line in other words its slope
is constant how do I write down the
equation of a linear function this you
must all remember you may have different
letters that you assigned to it that is
the function might be equal to B plus MX
so y equals B plus MX is the way I
learnt it but you may have seen y equals
BX plus C or something like that okay
the the quantity that is that multiplies
the input variable is the slope
coefficient and the quantity that is on
its own is the constant term also known
as the y-intercept okay let's just draw
a quick
in the Cartesian plane if I were to draw
this as the straight line what quantity
is this B right that's the y-intercept
okay and if if you don't remember that
just keep in mind that the y-intercept
is of course the point at which X is
equal to 0 anytime you're on the
y-intercept X is equal to 0 so you would
substitute 0 in here and so Y would be
equal to B what about this point here
what what what about this distance here
sorry this is U so you're actually right
this is the x-intercept and what what is
the quantity that I'm looking for so
you'll have to do a little bit of
algebra ok so let's just take a step to
do that ok so so let's let's do that a
little bit more slowly y is equal to MX
plus B this holds everywhere on the line
we are looking for a point on the x
intercept which means the Y value is of
course equal to 0 so we are looking for
the point the sub set of all these
points where Y itself is equal to 0 so
we want the value of x where Y is equal
to 0 so that's MX
so X is equal to minus B over m okay
okay so just keep that in mind and I
think that's exactly what we just did
okay
okay now the slope of course is also
known as the rise over the run you'll
find this very useful on Thursday when
we start talking about calculus for
linear functions the slope is a simple
concept it's a fixed number the
coefficient of x in this case M it
indicates two things both steepness and
direction right so if the slope M is a
large number has large magnitude then it
is a very steep function okay you could
think of it in terms of grade this is a
very steep function that is M is very
large this is a relatively shallow
function M is relatively small so M low
M high this is a this is a very steep
function with a negative M so this would
be minus M H and this would be minus M L
okay a relatively shallow declining
function
okay we use the concept of slope to
define linear functions as opposed to
nonlinear functions any function that
has a constant slope is a linear
function any function whose slope
changes for different values of X is a
nonlinear function okay so this is a
nonlinear function here it is steeply
downward sloping here it's gradually
downward sloping here it's flat
here it's steeply upward sloping so its
slope changes it is a nonlinear function
so let's talk about equations of those
linear functions we'll stay in the world
of linear functions for a little while
suppose you know only the slope of a
linear function can you derive its
equation I have a bad habit of asking
questions and putting the answers on the
board
but actually in my in the economics
class you you are required to sign up
for a class where you're going to be on
the hot seat and you have to answer
questions on the readings for that class
and to everybody else but often the
questions I asked the answers are on the
board
but but sometimes people are so stunned
that they're asked that they still don't
answer okay so of course the slope if
you just know the slope of a linear
function you cannot construct its
equation why
yes rich okay okay so that's a good
question
if you know the slope and let's say as a
result you know two points on the line
why could you not know the equation is
there a flaw in what I just said what's
the flaw you don't know two points on
the line because you know the slope
right and look and let's take a look at
the picture okay so suppose Richard you
tell me that the slope is equal to one
okay that means it has a 45 degree angle
to the origin that means that I know
that M is equal to one
right so they so I know I know
the class of equations that it falls
into but not the exact one okay but it's
a good question because you see
econometrics and statistics in general
is about establishing lines from unknown
information and there are often times
when you know only the slope
it shouldn't paralyze you knowing the
slope still means you know quite a lot
okay for example you know you don't know
the equation of that line but you know
the equation two and two one unknown
that is the constant okay so there are
some things that even this will tell you
for example this tells you that is
knowing that your functional
relationship is described by any one of
these three lines tells you that if you
were to increase X by a certain amount
you would know what the likely impact on
Y would be that's the very definition of
slope right there rise over the run so
knowing the slope and not knowing the
intercept might still tell you a lot
about a relationship so so get used to
this type of questioning that Richard
just did because it should it should
allow you to engage with your exact
level of knowledge without you know
without shutting you down or without
silencing you if you don't have
everything that the cookbook recipe
needed you to have now if you only know
the y-intercept of a linear function
again you would not be able to give me
the equation
and the picture is going to be a little
bit different okay okay can someone tell
me if you know the y-intercept of a
linear function so that means I know B
but I don't know M so suppose that that
B is here so I know that it crosses here
what are some of the different lines
that would satisfy that sorry what's
your name
Monika a whole wheel of potential lines
right so it would might look like that
sorry my drawing is terrible here okay
so any of these so actually what's very
interesting is that what character is
your knowledge if you just know the
y-intercept its it's a firm up or a
character than if you just knew the
slope because if you're look trying to
look at the relationship between x and y
knowing the slope can actually tell you
quite a bit and in fact it's quite
routine in statistical analysis to not
know what the what the intercept is but
to know just the slope but knowing not
knowing the slope means you virtually
know nothing because it's highly
unlikely that you're going to be
interested in the one case where X is
equal to zero and that's all you can
talk about if you just know that the the
y-intercept right okay okay now so in
order to derive the equation either you
have to know both the slope and the
y-intercept or as Richard pointed out if
you knew two points on the line you
could construct the slope and you could
also construct the y-intercept
okay and so let's let's do a problem
like that
okay so we have to find the equation of
the line which has a slope of 4 and a
set of coordinates 3 - 2 right and I'd
like to try to do that graphically
initially so that you get a sense of the
intuition and then we'll we'll look at
how that's done algebraically ok ok so I
think this is the Greek way of solving
the problem that is geometrically and
then we'll do it the Arab way of solving
the problem which is algebraically ok so
it has a slope of 4 so we know that it
is a relatively steep slope could be any
one of these lines and we know that one
of the points on the line is 3 - 2 3 - 2
is something like that this is 3 and
this is 2
ok so we're really looking for a line
like this so I know that 3 might this is
3 - 2 useful piece of information would
be to know what B is right
B is probably down here so how might I
find out that B from this yes what's
your name Sarah okay that's just from so
let's let's go let's just get used to
that it's something you should
internalize ok I don't know this is
going to stay up
the slope is the rise over the run so
suppose that the rise is equal to the
run the slope would then be 1 over 1
which is 1 and so that would have a
45-degree angle and here the slope is
equal to 1 if the slope was 1 in 10
the rides was 1 for every run of 10
you'd only have a small rise for a long
run so this would be the slope so here
the slope is 1 in 10 similarly a slope
of 4 would mean a rise of 4 for a run of
you see so that's why it would look like
that ok
okay so we're looking for this intercept
I know the slope is 4 I know this point
is 3 so how would I find out this point
just thinking geometrically yes perfect
okay everybody see that okay she's a
fast she's a fast think so
graphically it's very helpful and in in
certain kinds well pretty much in in all
sorts of problems it's always helpful to
understand the equations graphically
okay and to know where you are
okay so I know that this point the the
y-intercept is minus 14 0 I know the
slope I'm sorry 0 minus 14 so B is
actually minus 14 so I know that Y is
equal to MX plus B which is 4x minus 14
and you could do a quick check to see if
this point what
make sense three times four is 12 minus
14 is minus 2 okay okay so and
presumably that's what we did okay this
is this is the algebraic way of doing it
which is really just the expression of
what we did okay so we've got we know
that the equation follows this form MX
plus B we know that M is 4 we're looking
for B and we let x1 we let this point
3-2 be x1 y1 and then we know that x1 y1
is on the line we let the wine to set B
x2 y2 which is the point here we're
trying to look for that point okay we
use the fact that the rise over the run
is 4 that's the rise over the run the
change in X is in the denominator the
change in Y is in the numerator and we
simply solve for X x1 we know that x2 is
0 because we're on the intercept ok and
then we solve so algebra this is algebra
of course algebra comes from an Arabic
word which means completion is about the
process of looking for an unknown so
there's always unknown in algebra which
you're trying to find okay in this case
the unknown that we
completed was the minus 14 okay okay so
here's another problem find the equation
the line which passes through now two
points so here we have a problem like
the one Richard suggested we have two
points we don't know the slope but of
course anytime you have two points you
can find the slope right there was a
long time ago there's a there still is a
restaurant on Amsterdam called Amsterdam
cafe it's been much renovated since I
used to go there as a as an undergrad
but there was a very mathematical waiter
there that's the sort of thing you find
in New York right mathematical waiters
and architect taxi drivers and so he is
so at some point I think a friend of
mine and I went in and we had one drink
and we were debating whether to have
another one or not and the guy showed up
the waiters came by and he said well if
you have one drink it's a point but if
you have two drinks it's a line so so
that was a way to sell sell another
drink and once you've had two you can
have an infinite number of drinks and
not feel bad about it okay so now so
let's let's let's find the slope here
minus 2 3 and 3/8 so let's so I haven't
quite drawn this right
okay
okay so I simply want to construct the
slope and of course it's going to be the
rise over the run and at this point you
probably at this point you're all
experts at this of course so what's the
rise it's the change in Y so 8 minus 3
right and what's the run is 5 right
everybody ok ok so that's M and you
could you could certainly just work out
what this is to get B okay okay so yeah